we do like technology and innovation at
the Gates Foundation but but I have to
say that you know when i hear technology
or innovation i often he think about a
widget or a new thing or an object what
i love about being at the foundation is
our affinity for innovation comes in a
lot of different flavors it may come in
product development it may be a new
vaccine or a new approach to how we
store or keep cold vaccines or move
vaccines around it might be using phones
to make sure that we have compliance or
we can find people when they need to be
vaccinated or their kids need some care
but one of my favorite forms of
innovation here at the foundation are
innovations and ways of operating our
passion is to solve problems let me give
you an example last year when Ebola
became a huge global issue because of
the outbreak in West Africa the Gates
Foundation didn't have programs in those
West African countries and we didn't
have a program in Ebola we had a
relatively small emergency fund for
things that often had been things like a
flood or tsunami or an earthquake so I
went to Bill and Melinda after many
phone calls that me and my colleagues
received about Ebola and suggested to
Bill and Melinda that we should put up
50 million dollars to try and help with
Ebola and Bill and Melinda graciously
and rapidly agreed that we should do
that well having no programs and no work
and seeing the enormity of the problem
we looked right away at a couple things
one is how could we help we could move
money quickly flexibly and make sure
that people on the ground in these West
African countries could rapidly get the
help they needed we could partner with
organizations that ranged from the wh 0
to UNICEF to the Centers for Disease
Control and work with these partners and
the ministries locally in the countries
that were involved to make sure that
those supplies that money got to where
it needed to get and so I think a bowl
in many ways showed our foundation at
its finest flexible moving quickly but
knowing how we could play a role
together with others and every step
along the way we were focused on what
can we do how can we use our resources
our intellect our human capital to help
fix this problem I think those are the
kinds of collaborative innovations how
we communicate regularity teamwork that
sometimes involve high tech we might use
a video conferencing or we might use a
smartphone but often are how human
beings interact together in novel ways
to get things done and that's at least
as important a way that we use
innovation here